thank you very much um what i'd like to
share with you today
are some of our results in the
evaluation of the
oncoming pan cancer cell free assay and
the prof in the profiling
of liquid biopsies and how these panels
can help accelerate translational
research studies
so these are my disclosures for today's
presentation
as well as disclaimers
so the presence of three nucleic acids
in the blood or other fluids has been
known for some time
getting back to the first reports in
1948
when free nucleic acids were detected in
the plasma of patients
almost 30 years later the interest in
cell-free
dna and rna surfaced again when a number
of scientists began
looking at the genomics of cell-free dna
in cancer patients
and demonstrated that they possessed um
tumor-associated aberrations
since then there has been increasing
interest in cell-free nucleic acids
um with what seems to be an explosion of
work over the past decades
and this timeline just shows some of the
uh discoveries leading up to that
tsunami of work
in recent years
there are many types of species of
nucleic acids that can be
obtained from liquid biopsies and these
include circulating tumor cells
cell-free dna rna microrna
mitochondrial dna and they can be also
encapsulated in
in exosomes and this allows for a
variety of profiling
across both dna and rna which can be
complemented
uh with standard biochemical protein
testing
or more sophisticated proteomic
profiling
while we most often immediately think
about blood
there are other types of liquid biopsy
sources and these include
urine sputum uh semen vaginal fluids
ascites or other secretions
i'm not going to spend a whole lot of
time in the slide but by now most of you
are aware of the advantages and
disadvantages
of liquid biopsy profiling but briefly
obtaining these types of samples are
largely non-invasive
which means that there are possibilities
for repeated sampling during the course
of a patient's clinical management
there are implications for using these
liquid biopsy biomarkers for early
disease detection
inform on prognosis inform on response
to treatment or disease progression
the high throughput technologies that
are available today
for profiling solid tissues have been
adapted to suit the specific challenges
associated with cell-free nucleic acids
and this enables assays to be performed
in routine
clinical settings and as we begin to
identify more biomarkers that are
prognostic and predictive the
translation
of these biomarkers in the liquid biopsy
space provides an added dimension to
personalized medicine
liquid biopsy profiling is already
influencing clinical trial design
and the related correlative studies
the challenges however are the biology
of
cancers are quite complex we know that
cancers are heterogeneous
they can be multi-clonal as well as
multifocal
we lose the spatial relationships of
these nucleic acids and how they might
be represented in the solid tumor
whether that is from the primary or the
metastatic site
and this can be complicated further by
the presence of several
metastatic sites other
factors that will influence the success
of liquid biopsy profiling
is the ability of the tumor to shed that
material
systemically nucleic acid shedding
through apoptosis and necrosis are
part of normal cellular processes but if
an
intervention influences these cellular
processes
say for example chemotherapy this would
need to be taken into consideration when
you're
thinking about doing liquid biopsy uh
profiling
in terms of collection or interpreting
the results
um the amount of circulating tumor dna
or rna will vary from patient to patient
and the yields obtained could be very
low so technologies
need to be able to deal with low input
and consider
aspects of their limits of detection
there are also things to consider in
terms of the sampling effect
some variants may be present at very low
level so it's conceivable that when you
repeat that same sample
you could reveal discordant calls so
these are the types of things we need to
think about
when we're profiling these liquid biopsy
sources
our work at the oicr focuses on
improving the clinical management of
early breast and prostate cancer
we have developed in our labs signatures
that could
inform on risk and could potentially
stratify
patients to targeted therapies however
we wanted to
identify whether there are profiling
panels that could help support this
translational work
what i'm going to present today are the
results of a small proof-of-concept
study
where we profiled a series of c2 dnas in
their matched solid tumors from breast
to lung
and a series of tumors of unknown origin
using the pan cancer panel
and the oncoming comprehensive assay we
also profiled urine specimens collected
from men who entered the clinic
on suspicion of prostate cancer
following their digital rectal exam
in this study we profiled the dna and
the rnas extracted from the urine using
the oncoming comprehensive assay
i just wanted to spend a few minutes to
talk about the limit of detection
that we obtained in our panel evaluation
i previously mentioned that the yield of
ctdna
is variable we've seen a range of
anywhere from 0 to 50 nanograms of ct
dna obtained per milliplasma
averaging about 11 nanograms that's not
very much material to work with
what we wanted to do is to see how low
we can go in terms of
input to assess this we used a
commercial control with known variants
at specific frequencies
and we decreased the input from the
optimal 20 nanograms and found that we
were able
to recapitulate the theoretical limits
of detection
as you can see in the graphs below
as we lowered the amount of input
the ability to have the variant called
or detected was compromised
although a variant might not have been
called
if you go into the actual sequencing
results you'll see that the variant was
actually detected
so what we found was that a 0.5
limit of detection could be achieved
with 10 nanograms of input
and a point one two five percent limit
of detection at 20 nanograms of input
could also be obtained using this
assay
this slide is just to remind you of our
methods and the samples that we used in
this study
and this is the result of the
study with the match dnas and solid
tissues
for each case there are two to three
assay results
the first sample to the left of each set
is a ct dna profiled with the ct
dna pain cancer panel the middle sample
is a solid tumor which was profiled with
the oncoming comprehensive assay
and the last sample to the right is a
solid tumor which was also profiled with
the ct dna pain cancer panel
we wanted to look at the concordance
between the cp dna
and solid tumor so we used the ct dna
assay on the solid tumor
as an added method of validation we use
the oncoming comprehensive assay
to the solid tumor arrows point to those
variants that
were detected in both the ct dna and the
solid tumor
we see the usual stuff suspects for
breast cancer including mutations and
picture ca
and and tp 53 as well as a detection of
the her2 amplification both in the ct
dna
and solid tumor
for the lung cancers we see mutations in
k-ras as well as p53
and a variety of variants
in the tissues of unknown origin
we were actually quite pleased with
these results and the level of
concordance or discordance
that we observed is in keeping with what
you might expect when
taking into account the specificity of
each assay
and the content overlap we're continuing
to analyze this data
informatically beyond the default filter
settings
to look at various levels of detection
we then moved on to profiling urine for
men who were seen in the clinic on
suspicion of prostate cancer
the urine was obtained following their
digital rectal exam
and extracted for both dna and rna
because there was limited dna we
prioritize an ngs based
methylation assay by using a custom
design methylation panel
and any remaining dna was used to
perform the oncoming comprehensive assay
for the rna that was extracted i
mentioned that we have derived
signatures that could predict risk for
early prostate cancer
one of those components is an rna
signature so we profile
the rna against the custom nanostring
gene expression panel
with the remaining rna we use the rna
component of the
oncoming comprehensive assay that
contains fusions associated with
prostate cancer
there were two samples with sufficient
dna after
um the methylation assay
using oncoming filter we identified that
there was an
actionable mutation in one of those
samples as you can see here
the met mutation for the rna portion of
the assay we're real
really pleased to have detected the temp
herb fusion product which is found in
approximately 50 percent
of prostate cancers and as you can see
we also identified
other fusions among these urine samples
in collaboration with thermal fissure
our prostate cancer initiative has led
to the development of a 38 gene
ngs methylation panel it's been
previously demonstrated in solid tissues
to
outperform methylation-specific pcr and
we wanted to extend the application of
this panel
um into dna extracted from urine what we
found was that the sequencing quality
and results obtained from urine derived
dna was
comparable to what was seen in dna that
we processed from ffpe tissues
we're currently obtaining the match
biopsies from these patients
and we'll run the assay to look at the
overall components between the match
samples in this figure you can see that
the extent of methylation
in a subset of these genes but
unfortunately i'm unable to share with
you
the the genes themselves at this time
but you can see the patterns of
differential methylation
across the different samples as it
relates to grades
which is noted uh to the right
what i hope i've demonstrated here today
is that these validated panels
and associated chemistries can support
discovery translation
and clinical grade profiling to address
the different clinical management needs
of
cancer patients in the future liquid
biopsy profiling alone
or when integrated with solid tissue
profiling can provide
key prognostic and predictive
information for early detection or
disease monitoring
at the oicr our groups have developed
prognostic gene signatures for hormone
receptor positive early breast cancers
in addition to signatures that predict
chemotherapy benefits based on solid
tissue profiling
our goal is to eventually extend this
into the liquid biopsy space to
determine whether
prognostic significance is maintained
similarly with respect to
early prostate cancer we have developed
and validated a prognostic signature for
grade
and working towards developing this in
urine which is the ideal fluid because
the anatomy
of the male urogenital system
so in summary ngs based profiling for
liquid biopsies is a high throughput
method for identifying key biomarkers
the oncoming family of products of solid
tissue and liquid biopsy profiling
provides high quality and robust data
for
discovery translational research and
in future clinical diagnostics
the key features of this assay are that
it requires very minimal
input it's suitable for ffp specimen
and nucleic acids that have been
extracted from liquid biopsies
there's a robust workflow they're
validated panels
and have an integrated informatics
workflow report generation
and finally i'd like to acknowledge our
collaborators both
at queen's university as well as thermo
fisher
as well as to the diagnostic development
team at the oicr
thank you very much and i'd be happy to
take your questions